[Music]
greetings 3bn family and welcome to
another 3bn today Bible Q&A I'm Ricky
Carter and I'll be your host well we've
got another hour pack program with your
Bible questions and we have the answers
found here in the word of God of which
our panel will be blessing us with those
answers so let me introduce you to our
panel right away next to me I have
sister Shelley Quinn welcome sister it
is a blessing to be here we want to one
again and thank you for sending in your
questions because it's our joy to answer
them amen amen and next to her we have
brother John densey welcome Pastor John
densey thank you it's a blessing to be
here and it's always a learning
experience this is one of those programs
where we should be ready with our Bibles
and something to write down amen amen
and next to him we have Pastor James
rafy welcome brother hey it's good to be
here I'm on the old monitor but good to
be here with you Ricky and Shelly and
John looking forward to a great program
today amen amen well before we get
started with reading God's word why
don't we start off with a word of prayer
Pastor deny could you lead us in word of
prayer please yes let's go our loving
Heavenly Father we want to thank you
once again for the holy scriptures that
are able to make us wise unto salvation
and Lord here we have many questions in
this world and we thank you that your
holy scriptures have answers for us to
help us and and light our pathway and
light Our Lives we pray Lord that you
will help us to dedicate more time to
study them bless us with your holy
spirit that we may give answers that
come from you we ask you in the holy and
blessed name of Jesus amen amen amen
amen well Pastor Deni I have your first
question but before I give that to you
let me remind our viewers at home how
you can participate you can participate
in one of three ways you can email us at
bible QA
3abn.org TV the second way you can text
us to 618 228 3975 that's 618 228
3975 and then for those of you who are
on Instagram you can send us your
questions in that way as well Instagram
at
3abn official at 3abn official okay
brother deny here we go first
question we keep the seventh day Sabbath
and will still be keeping it in eternity
but if we will be keeping the lunar
month-to Monon sabbaths and Eternity
also then why do we not keep them now
that was texted to us from
Pennsylvania thank you so much for the
question and uh we do not keep that
because it is not according to what we
should do basically uh when you look at
this word in Isaiah 66 verse 22 and 23
which is what you referring to and I
like to read that now for as the new
heavens and the new Earth which I will
make shall remain before me sayeth the
Lord so shall your seed and your name
remain and it shall come to pass that
from one new moon to another and from
one Sabbath to another shall All Flesh
come to worship before me saith the Lord
so this is the King James version and
many other versions May render it just
that way from one new moon to another
but there are versions of the Bible that
also render it from one month to another
well why do some render it from one new
moon to another to another new moon and
some render it from month to month it is
because it is the context that
determines what is supposed to be
whether it says new moon or month to
month here the translators did the best
they could but when you look at this
word kodesh or hodesh in the Hebrew it
can mean month monthly and it can mean
new moon there are about 279 occurrences
in the Bible and of those
279 only 10 it is translated new moon in
the King James version now should this
one be translated new moon or month to
month I would say to you that is better
to say month to month for example I can
tell you the Spanish version of the
Bible the very earliest translation of
the Bible uses the word month to month
what what does that mean to you well
that means that I suggest you look at
different versions of the Bible to see
how they render this text how they say
this text and ask yourself is it is it
saying really from one new moon to
another and why does the Lord need new
moons to gather his people together well
the rendering here when you see this
combination of words it is as often as
it is occurs or as often as God appoints
when God appoints it that's when we
shall be there but the seventh day
Sabbath is a day that God has Sanctified
and set apart holy for Holy purpose and
so in the new Earth we will still be
keeping the seventh day Sabbath so for
that reason we should not look at that
we should not look and say well we need
to be keeping new moons no there is no
reason to keep the new moons when you
look in the Old Testament you can see
that in the Book of Numbers it was said
to them that they should uh for example
at the beginning of the month it says
that they are to offer sacrifices
uh that were determined by Moses and so
but when you look at the sacrifices
every day there was a morning sacrifice
and an evening sacrifice at the
beginning of the month they were told to
sacrifice certain animals because it was
the beginning of the month but none of
those new or the beginning of the months
were actually considered a day of rest
and set apart as holy Moses never
indicated that he only specified IED the
seventh month to keep holy why the
seventh month because on the 10th day of
that seventh month was the day of
atonement the trumpets were blown to
indicate get ready the day of atonement
is coming so that was the only day but
when you look at the history of the Jews
they looked at the beginning of a new
month oh the new month and they started
doing some things but it that uh they
started doing some feasting and some
things like that to specify the Lord
blessed us to come to arrive at the
beginning of another month but it is
never been set apart as every single
beginning of the month as a holy day the
seventh day Sabbath yes but the new moon
no there's more but time is limited
thank you thank you very much sir all
right sister Shelly here's your first
question yes what is blasphemy against
the Holy Spirit I thought it was when
you harden your heart against hearing
the promptings of the spirit but Mark 3:
29 and 30 says that when you say he has
an unclean Spirit you have committed
blasphemy against the holy spirit is
hardening your heart so you don't hear
the prompting of the Holy Spirit
something else that I'm not
understanding please help me so I don't
commit blasphemy against the Holy Spirit
that's from Heather in Canada who texted
that to us Heather I can hear your
precious heart cry and we all want to be
sure that we understand this what does
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit let's
first think I'm going to give you a list
of scriptures what is the role of the
holy spirit in Salvation John 168
through1 his role is one of con uh
conviction not in a condemning way but
in a convincing way he convicts
individuals of sin righteousness and
judgment John 6:44 and Romans 2:4 says
his role is to draw people to Christ and
he enables repentance Ephesians 4:30
says we can grieve the Holy Spirit first
Thessalonians 5:19 says we can quench
the Holy Spirit blasphemy against the
holy spirit is not a single act but a
persistent refusal to respond to his
work it's a willful resistance that
leads to a hardened heart it is
considered the unpardonable sin Mark
3:29 and3 is what you mentioned let's
read that he who blasphemes against the
Holy Spirit never has forgiveness but is
subject to Eternal
condemnation because now he's going to
tell us why they said that he has an
unclean Spirit what in the context
What's Happening Here the religious
leaders all although they're seeing
Divine evidences they're seeing the
Miracles they know they should have
known that Jesus is fulfilling prophecy
and the Holy Spirit was trying to to
absolutely convict them but they
continued to reject in a deliberate way
they were trying to trap Jesus to to to
shut down his ministry and what happened
is
their ongoing rejection of the holy
spirit's convicting work is what caused
them to say he has an unclean spirit
so they were this was intentional it was
false it was malicious they were doing
this on purpose you know Jesus says that
the blasphemy against the holy spirit is
not forgivable that's in Matthew 1231
and 32 and Mark 328 through3 that we
just read why is it unpardonable let me
tell you this it's not because God
refuses to
forgive it's because an individual
reaches a point where they no longer
respond to the Holy Spirit they no
longer his his promptings make no
difference and they it makes repentance
impossible it's a unique sin because it
involves shutting ourself off from the
only means by which repentance and
forgiveness are available to us you know
first John 1:9 says that if we confess
our sins God is faithful and just to
forgive us and to cleanse us of all
unrighteousness but what happens here we
know that the the repentance process is
Godly sorrow confession and then turning
away from this sin but if we silence
the spirit's voice in our hearts we lose
the capacity to feel that conviction
here's warning signs of the unpardonable
sin repeatedly resisting the holy
spirit's convictions justifying sinful
behavior and refusing to repent
hardening our hearts against the truth
rejecting God's grace openly denying the
work of the Holy Spirit or attributing
it to Satan second Peter 3:9 Our God
wants all to turn to him come to a
knowledge of Jesus and be saved but the
unpardonable sin is not about God's
unwillingness to forgive it's about a
person's refusal to accept his
forgiveness so here's what I want to
tell you Heather it's a good sign when
you
ask am I guilty if you're worried about
this it shows still sensitive to the
leading and as long as you're sensitive
to the holy spirit's leading and wanting
to please God you're in good shape amen
amen thank you sister all right Pastor
James here's your first question what
does Isaiah chapter 4 verse one mean and
that's from V in New Jersey who texted
that to us thank you V great question
Isaiah chapter 4 and verse one is
actually the beginning of a a six verse
Bible prophecy that pertains to the end
of times we could actually say that
these verses in Isaiah chapter uh did I
say chapter six or chapter 4 chapter 4
these verses in chapter 4 excuse me are
paralleling or supplementing Revelation
chapter 13 and 14 and the mark of the
beast and the Three Angels messages now
let's just take a look at them and see
if we can shed some light on them in the
short time that we have and as we do
that I'll share with you a number of
Bible verses that you can go back and
study to get a little bit more uh
Insight on this so it starts in in
Isaiah 4 vers1 and in that day seven
women shall take hold of one man saying
we will eat our own bread and we will
wear our own apparel only let us be
called by thy name to take away our
reproach now that day is referring to a
prophetic period or a prophetic time and
I'm going to suggest It's the End of
Time seven is a number that's used to
designate complete or perfect and women
is symbolic of God's church or a false
Church an Unfaithful church so you've
got all of the churches taking hold of
one man and that would be Jesus Christ
he is the man and saying we will eat our
own bread that would be Christian
doctrine according to John chapter 6:35
where Jesus says I'm the bread of life
we'll eat our own bread we'll wear our
own apparel that would be the
righteousness of Jesus Christ according
to Revelation 19:8 only let us be called
by thy name that is let us be called
Christians acts 11:26 tells us that
Christians were first named so in
Antioch to take away our approach and of
course their approach is identified in
Zechariah Chapter 3:3 the filthy
garments that only Jesus Christ can take
away and replace with his righteousness
so you have a prophecy here that
speaking of a time when all the
Christian churches will come together
and they'll call themselves Christians
they'll call themselves by the name of
Christ but they want to they want to
have their own doctrines they want to
wear their own righteousness so that
they are not feeling the reproach or the
accusations that come against them for
being unfaithful to God in that Day
verse two the branch of the Lord shall
be beautiful and glorious and the fruit
of the Earth shall be excellent and
comeing for them that are escaped of
Israel that doesn't mean escape from
Israel it means those who of Israel who
are escaped out of this um configration
you uh ecumenical uniting of all these
churches and you can look at Daniel
11:41 and 121 to see who will be
delivered or who will escape out of the
hand of this in time movement verse
three and it shall come to pass in that
day that he that is left in Zion and he
that remains in Jerusalem that word
remains connects with uh the uh Remnant
we'll look at that the remaining ones
we'll look at that in another question
Shall be Called holy even everyone
that's written among the living in
Jerusalem Revelation 12:17 The Remnant
Revelation 14:1 Mount Zion Revel or
Hebrews 1222 and 23 God's Church of the
firstborn when the Lord shall have
washed away the filth of the daughters
of Zion and shall Purge the blood of
Jerusalem in the midst thereof with the
spirit of judgment with the spirit of
burning Matthew 13 36-42 the wheat and
the tears are separated and the Lord
will create upon every Dwelling Place of
Mount Zion and upon her assemblies a
cloud and a smoke this is talking about
reminds us of the Deliverance in of
Moses and God was with them in a pillar
of cloud by day and a fire by night and
that of course parallels Revelation 15
2-4 singing the song of Moses and the
lamb and finally that God will be a
shadow from the Heat and refuge that's
Psalm 911 and2 which we had more time
but I hope this gives you some Bible
verses for better study as you continue
to understand this prophecy amen you
need to do a sermon on that one James
yes that's what I'm thinking really yes
yes okay pastor densey here's your
second
question do I have to pay do I have to
pay my monthly tithes all at once and
that was emailed to
us thank you very much that's a good
question as well and we have to to ask
ourselves some questions when we ask a
question sometimes and so did the Lord
give you all of your money at one at
that one time and if the Lord bless you
with all the money at that time you have
the money it's time to give the tie to
the Lord to return the tie to the Lord
so um you know after living about 60
years or so on this Earth uh I know how
a little bit how the mind works and so
uh sometimes also we know how deceptive
the devil can be and when we look at
this and we say well I've got the money
but I've got these other things to keep
the money for some reason other than
well I can't I can't uh take the tithe
this time but even on people can do this
even online now so it's it's uh when we
have it when the Lord blesses us with it
it's the best time to give it otherwise
we give room we give space for the devil
to bring temptation to us to use it for
something else now please consider
Malachi 3:1 bring are the tithes into
the storehouse that there may be food in
my house and try me now in this day says
the Lord of hosts try him if I will not
open for you the windows of heaven and
pour out for you such a blessing that
there will not be room enough to receive
it so when I look at this I have to ask
myself do we want to do we want to uh
limit the Lord from blessing us by
holding on to the tithe when we think we
have a a a a better time when things
look a little better for us then we will
return the tithe to the Lord so the
sooner you return the tithe to the Lord
the sooner you're opening the door for
the lord to bless you and prepare the
blessing that there's not room enough to
receive it so I say to you uh I
encourage you to return the tithe when
you have the funds that the Lord has
given to you and he will bless you
remember the Lord promised there's a
promise in Philippians chapter 4 4: 19
that my God shall supply all your needs
according to his riches and glory and
the Lord says try me trust me in this
trust me I will pour out a blessing to
you amen thank you brother deny all
right sister shelle I've got your second
question okay can you please explain 1
Corinthians chapter 15: 28 if Jesus and
God are equal why does Jesus have to be
subject to God God as described in this
verse that's from Jenny in Washington
who texted that to us Jenny I love this
question and first let me just say up
front remember Jesus is fully human as a
human he was the Covenant Son of God he
is also fully Divine he was the second
person is the second person of the
godhead who stepped out of heaven and
came to Earth to become a human so this
reference is not about Christ's role in
the godhead or the
Trinity they they have a harmonious
relationship of equality there is no uh
hierarchy Jesus is fully Divine and
equal to the father we see this in
Philippians 2:6 where it says that he
did not consider equality with God
something to be used to his own
Advantage but he humbled himself to
become a man we see it in John 1 1-3 in
the beginning was the word the word was
with God the Word was God and he the he
everything that was made was made
through him John 10:30 he said I am the
father are one so now let's go to your
question 1 Corinthians
15:28 it's Paul writes now when all
things are made subject to him this is
the person of Jesus Christ then the son
himself this is the Covenant Son of God
will also be subject to him who put all
things under him that God may be all in
all at the end of this evil age or or
the end of the evil age is when the
resurrection happens and so this is when
we will put on
immortality and death will lose its
sting according to 1 Corinthians 15:25
and 26 death is The Last Enemy to be
destroyed so the sun this is Covenant
language it's speaking to Christ human
nature it's speaking of Christ as the
last Adam the representative of humanity
who's in perfect submission to God and
once sin is eradicated Christ's role of
mediation and his mission to defeat the
power of sin and death will be completed
the son himself the human Covenant Son
of God as the last Adam will be subject
to God's Divine will it's not about
inferiority but it is about perfect
Unity Christ's goal is to restore the
universe to its original order where
God's sovereignty is universally
recognized Hebrews 1:8 though listen
what the Lord says this is the father
speaking about the son and he says about
the son your throne oh God will last
forever and ever a scepter of Justice
will be the scepter of your kingdom this
passage is addressing Christ as God
himself and his eternal Reign Revelation
11:15 there were voices in heaven saying
the kingdoms of this world have become
the kingdoms of our Lord and of his
Christ he shall reign forever and ever
he will reign in his former glory in his
place within the godhead all things will
be subject to God 1 Corinthians 15:28
does not diminish Christ's divinity or
equality with God instead his subjection
to the father at the end signifies the
completion of his Redemptive work and
the restoration of all things to God's
Authority wow amen thank you
sister all right Pastor James here's
your second question are the remnants of
the end time a particular denomination
or are they yet to be revealed from
various denominations that's from John
and Ghana who emailed that to
us well that is a very important
question John thank you for asking that
question I'm sure many viewers are going
to be benefited by this question you
know the short answer is yes and yes the
REM of the end time is a particular
denomination identified specifically in
Revelation
12:17 as well as another six times in
the Book of Revelation chapters 12-15 so
the remnant Church is is clearly
identified in the Book of Revelation now
the remnant of the end time is also yet
to be revealed as clearly noted in
Revelation 18: 1-4 let's take a look at
these Verses first and see how we can
connect them with Christ's words in
another gospel the Gospel of John in
chapter 10 so Revelation 18 1-4 says
this after these things I saw another
Angel come down from heaven having great
power and the Earth was lightened with
his glory and he cried mly with a strong
voice voice saying Babylon the great is
Fallen has fallen has become the
habitation of devils and the hold of
every foul Spirit and the cage of every
unclean and hateful bird for all nations
have drunk of the wine of the wrath of
her fornication and the kings of the
Earth have committed fornication with
her and the merchants of the Earth are
waxed Rich through the abundance of her
Delicacies and I heard another voice
from SE Heaven saying come out of her
here's the word my people that you be
not partakers of her sins and that you
receive out of her plague so there's
God's Remnant people in the end of time
that are not yet in God's Remnant Church
they're in Babylon they are in this
religio political system that has
corrupted the Earth with her doctrines
and sorceries so according to these
verses God's has a Remnant people that
are in Babylon we might even suggest
that the majority of God's Remnant
church or Remnant people are still in
Babylon prior to its fall and of course
we need to study that little further and
the need to heed the call to come out
before God pours out his seven last
plagues upon this relig political power
this system that's corrupting the world
with our unfaithfulness to God is vital
for God's Remnant people so this Remnant
church is identified that is the remnant
Church they're to come into they're
coming out of Babylon they're coming
into the remnant church and the remnant
Church uh that keeps the Commandments of
God is identified in Revelation 12 and
verse 17 they keep the Commandments of
God they have the testimony of Jesus and
the system of Babylon which is I think
named well has confused people regarding
the law of God the Commandments of God
claiming it was nailed to the cross or
done away with and this intentional
changing in violation of God's Ten
Commandment law and especially the
seventh day Sabbath has literally
corrupted the world all nations drunk of
her fornication right her unfaithfulness
to God and to his word and Jesus then
speaks about the fact that the part of
God's Remnant church are still in other
Fs in John chapter 10 let's look at
these verses verses 14- 16 Jesus says
I'm the Good Shepherd I know my sheep
and they are known of mine and and known
of mine and as the father knoweth me
even so I know the father and I lay down
my life for the Sheep other sheep I have
there it is which are not of this fold
so Jesus has a fold he has a fold it's a
Remnant church and then he has other
sheep that are not of this fold them
also must I bring and they will hear my
voice and there shall be one fold and
one Shepherd so Jesus knows his true
sheep that are in this fold and he knows
his sheep that are in other folds and
they're going to hear his voice just
like we read there in Revelation 18 so
notice here that Christ is directing us
to listening to the voice that says come
out of her my people out into what out
into God's end time Remnant Church keep
all 10 of God's Commandments as the
Fulfillment of the New Covenant in
Revelation 8: 6 through 12 the New
Covenant which promises to put God's law
in our heart and in our minds amen amen
thank you very much sir all right Pastor
deny I've got your third question but
before I give that to you let me remind
our viewers and listeners how they can
participate one of three ways you can
send us your questions into you can
email them to us at bible QA 3m. that's
Bible QA 3m. or you can text us 618 228
3975 that's 61822 8 3975 and for those
of you on Instagram at 3abn official at
3abn official okay brother deny here we
go did Satan have access to go back and
forth to heaven and other worlds until
Christ died on the cross and that was
texted to us thank you so much uh let's
go right away to Job chapter
1 in Job chapter 1 we have beginning in
verse 6 a seen and it says now there was
a day when the sons of God came to
present themselves before the Lord and
Satan also came among them and the Lord
said to Satan from where do you come so
Satan answered the Lord and said from
going to and fro on the earth and from
walking back and forth on it this is
showing that he has possession Dominion
that he can go wherever he wants and so
continuing in ver verse 8 then the Lord
said to Satan have you considered my
servant job that there is none like him
on the earth a blameless and upright man
one who fears God and shuns evil so this
meeting uh tells us apparently that
Satan had opportunity to go to heaven or
wherever this meeting was so did he have
access at this point yes we can see that
here very clearly now when you go to uh
Revelation 12 and Ezekiel chapter 28 we
see something that helps us understand
that Satan has had uh a series of of
limitations placed upon him let's go to
Ezekiel 28:1 15 and 16 it says Thou was
perfect in thy ways from the day that
thou was created till the iniquity was
found in thee so when iniquity is found
in him uh then we see that Revelation 12
paints to us a picture of war and it
says uh I I'll read verse 16 of Ezekiel
28 first the multitude of th merchandise
they have filled the midst of thee with
violence and thou has sinned therefore I
will cast thee as profane out of the
Mountain of God and I will destroy thee
or covering cherub from the midst of the
stones of fire this destroying is yet
future Revelation
127 and so the first time Satan is cast
out of Heaven first one uh now and there
was war in heaven Michael his angels
fought against the dragon and the dragon
fought and his angels and Prevail not
neither was their place found anymore in
heaven they're cast out the second phase
of this is when he uh has success and uh
deceives Adam and Eve uh verse uh
continuing in Revelation 129 and the
Great Dragon was cast out that old
serpent called The Devil he's cast into
the earth when he deceives Adam and Eve
he came he didn't have complete access
and Authority on the earth until until
Adam and Eve sinned he when Adam and Eve
sinned he now has a place he has a
headquarters where he can put his camp
and Revelation 12:9 says he deceived the
whole world and he was cast out into the
Earth and his angels were cast out with
him now Revelation 1210 and I heard a
loud voice saying in heaven now has come
salvation and strength and the kingdom
of our God and the power of His Christ
so this is signifying a moment when
Jesus dies on the cross salvation is now
set and assured because by before this
it was a promise based on the sacrifice
of Christ and when Jesus dies on the
cross now Satan is notice how how it is
it is is placed uh and the accuser of
our Brethren is cast down which accuse
before accuse them before our God day
and night this casting down here is a
limitation placed upon him that he
doesn't have access to Heaven he does he
cannot go up there
uh to accuse he can accuse from here and
if he has access to go to to go up there
he cannot go in he's been cast out they
don't listen to him anymore he accusing
our Brethren you're finished you know
your time is you've been defeated we
know who you've been unmasked and so now
this is no more access to these places
the time is limited so we have to stop
amen thank you for that detailed answer
all right sister Shelly here's your
third question
where does the Bible mention fire and
brimstone I would like to know more I
think it has to do with volcanos that's
from Jennifer Marshall in South Carolina
who texted that to us well Jennifer what
is firing Brimstone we know that
consuming fire is known for purification
or for Destruction Brimstone is a term
for sulfur and it's a highly flammable
mineral that burns
exceedingly hot in the natural realm
yeah it is associated with volcanic
eruptions and other natural disorders in
scripture when were they talking about
the source of fire and brimstone it's
from God so he uses them to execute
judgment whether it's through
Supernatural means or natural phenomenon
under his control I don't know but in
the Bible fire and brimstone signify
Divine judgment M and destruction the
first time it appears is in Genesis
19:24 the Lord reigned upon Sodom and
upon gomorah Brimstone and fire from the
Lord Out of Heaven so we see it's a
supernatural origin it came from God in
heaven came down as fire and brimstone
this is God's
intervention as a form of judgment Jude
7 says that Sodom and gomorra were set
forth as an example of Eternal fire well
they're not on fire yet today but the
Eternal aspect of it is the fire didn't
go out until its purpose was finished
Psalm 11:6 says upon the wicked he will
rain coals fire and brimstone and a
burning wind shall be the portion of
their cup so fire and brimstone are
metaphors for God's judgment on the
wicked and this imagery of this burning
sulfur I think it kind of reinforces the
idea of the intensity of this and the
severity of the Judgment that's
described so it is has a
consuming
nature that's because it's divine
Justice it recurs throughout scripture
especially in the apocalyptic text of
Revelation let me give you a couple real
quickly Revelation
14:10 he himself shall also drink of the
wine of the wrath of God which is poured
out full strength into the cup of his
indignation he shall be tormented with
fire and brimstone it's interesting this
is New King James uh the NIV says with
burn fire and burning sulfur in the
presence of the Holy Angels and in the
presence of the Lamb Revelation 20110
the devil who deceived them was cast
into the lake of fire and brimstone
that's a lake of burning so again in NIV
Revelation 218 the Cowardly unbelieving
abominable murderers sexually immoral
Sorcerers idolators and all liars shall
have their part in the lake which burns
with fire and brimstone
which is the second death no one will
survive the lake of fire and brimstone
this is the Eternal destruction of God
of Satan and his followers right God be
praised amen amen thank you very much
sister all right Pastor James is your
third
question what is the connection of Jesus
and the Order of mzc and that was
emailed to us thank you for that
question Hebrews chapter 6 and 7 makes
this connection uh of Jesus to the order
of mzc let's take a look at the verses
and see what they tell us right Hebrews
chapter 6 and we'll start with verse 20
Hebrews 6:20 says with the Forerunner is
for us entered even Jesus made a high
priest Forever After the order of
melchisedec so Jesus has been made a
high priest Forever After the order MDC
that's what we have so far right so what
about mzc or why mzc who was this priest
and why would he be a type or a shadow
of the priesthood of Jesus Christ well
let's continue to read in chapter 7 of
the book of Hebrews Hebrews 7 beginning
with verse one and we'll read through
verse three for this mkis DEC king of
Salem priest of the most high so king of
Salem priest of the most high God who
met Abraham returning from the slaughter
of the Kings and blessed him to whom
Abraham gave one tenth part of all being
first by interpretation king of
righteousness and after that also king
of Salem which is king of peace without
father without mother without descent
having neither beginning of days nor end
of life but made like unto the Son of
God abideth the priest continually so
here we have the direct connection to
Jesus Christ there are three basic
connections that we see here that answer
your question number one melkisedek is
described as the king of righteousness
and we know that Jesus Christ is the
Lord our righteousness and he is the
king of kings Jeremiah 23:6 and mzc
number two was a king or the king of
Salem OR the king of Peace uh Salem
means peace and Jesus is a king and he
is our peace according to Ephesians
chapter 2 and verse 14 and then finally
number three MDC had no recorded
beginning or end of days all right the
record isn't there and we know this is a
shadow a type of Christ it points to
Christ because Christ is also I mean is
eternal and self-existent I'm not saying
melkisedek is and he has no beginning
and he has no end of days amen thank you
sir thank you very much all right Pastor
densey here's your final
question will there be a Rapture of the
church before the tribulation or will
Believers have to endure the wrath of
God that's from Dave in Georgia who
chatted that to
us thank you very much I like the way
your question is worded um let's go
ahead and go to John chapter 16 verse 30
uh 33 these things Jesus said I have
spoken unto you that in me you might
have
peace in the world ye shall have
tribulation but be of good cheer I have
overcome the world um I'm going to go
ahead and pause here and tell you
that the church God's people God's
obedient people will be here during the
tribulation mhm but God protects them
during the time of tribulation amen God
is with them Jesus will be with us he
will protect us just as he protected the
the Israelites during the plagues that
were falling upon Egypt the plagues were
falling upon the Egyptians but the Jews
were not receiving the plagues let's go
to Revelation 7: 13 and 14 it says
there and one of the elders answered and
said unto me what are these which are
arrayed in white robes and when came
they and I said unto him sir thou
knowest and he said to me these are they
which came out of Great Tribulation and
have washed their robes and made them
white in the blood of the Lamb so yes we
will have to go to the tribulations but
God protects us now you mentioned the
wrath of God will the Believers have to
endure the wrath of God no notice Romans
1:18 for the wrath of God is revealed
from Heaven against all ungodliness and
unrighteousness of men who hold the
truth and unrighteousness so those that
are evil those that are unrighteous are
the people that are going to endure the
wrath of God they're going to suffer the
wrath of God Colossians 3 5 and 6
mortify Therefore your members which are
upon the Earth fornication uncleanness
inordinate inordinate affection evil
concupiscence and covetous
which is idolatry for which thing sake
the wrath of God cometh on the children
of Disobedience the wrath of God is upon
the children of Disobedience Revelation
149 and10 and the third Angel followed
them saying with a loud voice if any man
worship the Beast and His Image and
receive his Mark in his forehead or in
his hand the same shall drink of the
wine of the wrath of God which is poured
out without mixture into the cup of his
indignation and he shall be tormented
with fire and brimstone in the presence
of the Holy Angels and in the presence
of the Lamb sister Shell read that a
moment ago so the wrath of God comes
upon the children of Disobedience not
the children of obedience what happens
to the children of obedience I like to
go to Psalm 91 and give you a picture
there he that dwelleth in the secret
place of the most high shall abide under
the shadow of the almighty amen I will
say of the Lord he is my refuge and my
Fortress my God in him I will trust he
will protect his people during the time
of tribulation they will not endure the
wrath of God Amen thank you very much
sir all right sister Shelly here's your
last
question did Adam have a wife before Eve
who is
lilth is this a demon Of Satan that's
from Mara in Colombia South Carolina who
emailed that to us Marsha I chose your
question on purpose because it is so
intriguing I don't know how I live to to
be this old without knowing about Lilith
she is a mythological figure rooted in
both
Mesopotamian and Jewish mythology now
catch that
mythology the earliest references to
Lilith Trace back to the mythology of
Mesopotamia it depicted her as a female
demon or a spirit that was associated
with nights and storms and illnesses and
even children snatching the depiction of
her character though evolved over time
and it embodied themes of Independence
and rebellion and even malevolence now
Jewish
folklore sometimes referred to Lilith as
supposedly the first wife of Adam
according to Folklore these are stories
that you tell around the campfire like a
fable a
thank
you according to the Fable she left Adam
because of a dispute over the equality
and then she refuses to go back into the
Garden of Eden which leads her down the
path to demonization over time so in the
cabal you've heard of the cabal this is
Jewish
mysticism they depict her as a seductive
demonist as evil figure but here's
what's so fascinating in contemporary
times Lilith is being embraced by
feminist movements and they have
reinterpreted her as a symbol of female
empowerment and autonomy I mean there's
images of her all over the it it just
illustrates the dynamic nature of a myth
and its ability to adapt to cultural
shifts but here's what I want to tell
you according to the Bible
Narrative of the both the creation and
the fall neither support these myths the
Bible narrative Adam's mate was created
from his rib he called her woman she was
deceived by Satan in the garden of the
serpent in the Garden of Eden and then
she handed Adam a piece of fruit he was
not deceived but he ate and Genesis 3:15
is soon as Sin entered the picture God
announced his Everlasting Covenant
saying I'll put enity he's talking to
the serpent between you and the woman
between your seed and her seed and he
you will bruise his heel but he will
crush your head so God instituted the
substitutionary sacrificial system
immediately and Adam and Eve did not die
that day but what they did is they knew
that the deliver was going to be coming
from her seed they thought it' actually
come from her loins but Adam named Eve
in Genesis
3:20 he named her the mother or Eve
which means the mother of all living so
the Bible clearly dispels any myth from
Jewish folklore or
Mesopotamian mythology or even the
feminist movement of today amen amen I
was wondering about this question so
thank you for a good answer all right
Pastor James I've got your last question
I've heard it taught that the Sabbath is
the Seal of God mentioning a scripture
that says the Holy Spirit seals us what
scriptures teach this that's texted to
us from
Missouri all right well this is such an
important question so thank you for
asking it you know we've often been
criticized as a church and perhaps
rightly so for failing to connect the
cealing of God's people with the Holy
Spirit and not just with the Sabbath so
first let's take a look in the Bible
what the Bible actually says and tells
us uh clearly I think about being sealed
with the Holy Spirit we're going to find
that in Ephesians chapter 1 beginning
with verse 12 it says that we should be
to the praise of his glory who first
trusted in Christ in whom also TR ye
trusted after that you heard the word of
Truth The Gospel of your salvation in
whom also after that you believe
believed you were sealed with the Holy
Spirit of Promise that's pretty clear
isn't it in fact in Ephesians it says
verse 30 of chapter 4 that we should
grieve not the holy spirit of God
whereby we are sealed under the day of
redemption so how does this relate to
the Sabbath we know the Sabbath is the
fourth Commandment we know the Ten
Commandments are a reflection of God's
character and we know that the holy
spirit is God okay so there's the
connection right there Matthew 22 36-40
tells tells us uh that God's character
is a character of love and of course the
holy spirit is part of the godhead if
we're sealed with the Holy Spirit we're
sealed with the character of God we're
sealed with the Commandments of God
we're sealed with the Sabbath truth
there's no disparen here there's
discrepancy here there's no uh
contradiction here between being sealed
with the Sabbath and being sealed with
the Holy Spirit they're one and the same
thing now all of this comes together
specifically in John 14: 15-1 17 notice
how Jesus puts this all together for us
beginning with verse 15 of John chapter
14 he says if you love me keep my
Commandments I love that verse love is
the motivation for keeping the
Commandments of God not salvation not
Merit not earning God's favor love is
the motivation of course we're told in
first John chapter 4 it we love him
because he first loved us so if you love
me keep my Commandments and then he says
this in verse 16 and I will pray the
father and he will give you another
comforter that he may abide with you
forever ever that means we're going to
be sealed with the comforter as we keep
the Commandments of god notice they're
both connected together you don't
separate them verse 17 even the spirit
of Truth whom the world cannot receive
because it seeth him not neither knoweth
him but you know him for he will dwell
with you and he will be in you he's
going to seal you into the truth and
that truth includes the law of God the
Commandments of God which are based on
the love of God so we are sealed with
the Holy Spirit by the Holy Spirit into
the love of God which is expressed in
our lives by keeping the Commandments of
God of course the New Covenant says I'm
going to put how is he going to do it
through his Spirit I'm going to put my
law into your hearts and write them in
your minds the Commandments are
reflection of God's character of love
the holy spirit is God so we seal with
the Holy Spirit is to be sealed with the
Commandments of one of which is the
Sabbath commandment it's all it's all
the same such an important question one
that has a clear biblical answer and I
just pray that God would help us to be
sealed with the spirit with the
character of God's love in Jesus name
amen amen amen that's great great all
right well we've been getting some
really great answers and very thankful
that we've got all the answers here in
the word of God you know I want to let
you know that a lot of these answers we
can find them on our website we've got a
website have you heard about it 3abn
Bible anwers.com It's a Wonderful site
where you can find answers to questions
from about divorce questions about what
happens when you die questions about the
Antichrist many many different Bible
questions our Bible studies are on there
now our Bible studies are on there amen
amen so you can check that site out 3abn
Bible anwers.com well we're going to
take a short break to remind you how you
can participate with 3n today Bible Q&A
so don't go away we'll be right
back if if you're enjoying our 3abn
Bible Q&A then tell your friends each
Monday we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org 2
283975 that's 618 228
3975 be sure to include your name and
where you live and then watch 3 Aban
Bible Q&A for answers from God's word
well thanks for coming back well we're
just about out of time but before we go
want to get some final thoughts from our
panel sister Shelly well once again I
just think the whole idea of Lilith is
interesting from from Mesopotamian and
Jewish folklore to the cabala and the
Jewish mysticism and now to the feminist
movement we've got to be so careful that
we don't make void the word of God by
man's tradition amen Amen brother JY I
want to add something about Isaiah
66:23 that talks about the keeping of
the new moon and the question was should
we be keeping if if we are going to be
keeping it then should we keeping it now
remember that it is from month to month
not new moon to New Moon and why should
we not keep it now nor then Colossians
2:16 and 17 no let no man therefore
judge you in meat or in drink or in
respect of an holiday or of the new moon
or of the Sabbath days which are a
shadow of things to come but the body is
of Christ now remember that this sabbath
days are talking about the ceremonial
Sabbath not the 7even day Sabbath that's
why Isaiah
66:23 it says that we will be keeping
the seventh day Sabbath so the the new
moons are a shadow of things to come
amen amen thank you and Pastor James yes
sir perhaps you would like to learn how
to answer Bible questions for yourself
or for others and not be always having
to tune in our 3abn Q&A well we have a
school of discipleship sod is what we
call it it's at 3abn sad.com and if you
go to that website you can learn about
the next school we have one or two of
them a year
they are onewe intensive and you can
register there and you can learn how to
study Greek how to study Hebrew how to
get into the word of God for yourself
how to defend your faith and and there
you will also have the opportunity uh to
be able to get the skills that all of us
have that help us to navigate a lot of
these Bible questions and then to be
able to share those skills with other
people in your church or in your
community so 3abn sad.com
register uh check it out register and
look for the next school amen amen well
I've been blessed with this program I'm
sure you have as well I'm glad that you
could join us I hope you can join us
next time but before we go I want to
leave you with this fun scripture song
be kind to one another tenderhearted
forgiving one another even as God even
as God even as God in Christ forgave you
Ephesians 4 verse 32 all right please
come back next time you'll be blessed
I'm sure
[Music]